[Musique]
oui mais par un autochtone simin sommes
en haleine depuis sept semaines pour me
remettre un petit peu des élections
américaines j'ai décidé de vous faire
graver plus légère pour vous parler nous
vend ce qui existe en ligne et dans la
vraie vie de rock you look rock et
mocassins roc boxe c'est un mouvement
qui a commencé en 2011 a été lancée par
une jeune fille jessie cratique de la
nation pueblo d'ailleurs c'est pour ça
que je porte aujourd'hui mes boucles
d'oreilles qui est fait par une artisane
pueblo elle a décidé de mettre en ligne
une photo de m
qui porte à ses mocassins et les porter
dans une place publique ce qui est
fantastique c'est qu'en 2013
le mouvement a pris encore plus d'un
voile parce que c'était devenu viral
mais au niveau beaucoup plus local
proche de m
mais en 2013 c'est devenu viral à
l'international le canada les etats-unis
partout où les communautés autochtones
fabrique et porte les mocassins ont
décidé d'embarquer et ce qui était
fantastique si que peu importe se
trouvait sur le globe
tu pouvais communiquer avec d'autres
nations en utilisant le mot clic rock
you re max et les déclinaisons d'europe
ne manque que ça avec les années sont
venus quand même s'installer
rokia mox 2013 2015 2020 et maintenant
les roms que max avait des dix minutes
et ont rajouté le nom un mot clé qui
représentait la nation pourquoi c'est
fantastique c'est quelle grâce aux
médias sociaux ont pesé sur ce mot clic
là et créer un volet culturel comme une
librairie visuels de mocassins qui sont
portés qui existent encore avec les
années la mouvance se développer on a
commencé à montrer et me casser mais
aussi les regalia on a même montré des
personnes qui fabriquent et leurs
mocassins dès qu'ils avaient appris à
faire alors moncassin un même pour
pouvoir le faire fièrement grâce à
l'apurement et on a aussi vu des fois
des mélanges culturels qui n'existait
pas ce que tu peux avoir deux nations
qui se rencontrer et tais toi mon amour
donc qu'est ce que tu fais situé
cherokee et en plus si wayne par exemple
si tu es tu veux montrer ta fierté le
match que tu veux montrer ça quant à une
paire de mocassins aux normes qui
représente deux nations différentes
et créent des modèles qui sont
interchangeables avec le temps les gens
ont découvert de plus en plus ce
qu'elles veulent et communauté
autochtone peut même intégrer des
éléments visuels qui n'avait rien à voir
avec les éléments traditionnels dont on
a vu des mocassins du personnage doha ou
des mocassins des bébés au delà des mots
clocks de mots bébé avec son cas on peut
se représenter visuellement
traditionnellement l'on peut aussi se
représenter dans une contempora lité qui
est nouvelle pour beaucoup de gens et
qui ne reflètent peut-être pas pour
beaucoup d'allochtones le fait que
l'identité tonnes est en progression
elles évoluent elles changent mais elle
reste très ancrée aussi dans cette
tradition qu'elle apprécie je vais vous
donner un exemple moi présentement c'est
comme si la nation innu je porte des
mocassins et qui sont faites en cuir
fumée de caribous avec le bout des pieds
qui sont plissées et le perlage qui est
perdante géométriques pour pouvoir ces
petites fleurs mais le perlage
représente vraiment beaucoup plus
vraiment c'est une paire de mocassins
king on peut regarder les mocassins de
quelqu'un et reconnaîtra nation ou de
quelle région ils viennent grâce à ce
qui est le mocassin d'ailleurs tellement
important pour nous que quand les
enfants sont nés j'ai demandé de l'aide
de ma famille de mes amis pour trouver
des mocassins et de cuir fumée de
caribou pour les b pour qu'ils puissent
en avoir une
une représentation culturelle de leur
vocation comprendrez qu'avec la
problématique qui est des d'effondrement
de la biodiversité avoir du cuir fumée
caribou c'est de plus en plus difficile
mais c'est quand même un élément très
culturelle et qui a influencé comment on
fait le mocassin
d'ailleurs la clé cuir de caribou est
tellement mince qui permet de faire un
pli très délicat et ça peut influencer
d'autres nations que la nation et nous
varions affaire le mocassin avec le club
fumée kerry wood ya j'en ai trouvé une
paire dans un magasin
de seconde main et vous pouvez voir que
c'est fait avec le cuir fumée caribou
mais que le puits n'est pas le même
même la décoration n'est pas la même je
pense que si je devais voir en plus dire
que j'ai trouvé une paire de mocassins
que je ne peux pas dire la nation
puisque je ne vais pas acheter sur le
territoire je regarde le mode le modèle
je regarde aussi la pointe du pied
comment il a été cousu et comment il a
été brodé
d'ailleurs même la forêt puisque
certaines nations utilise pas les mêmes
fourrure pour décorer leurs mocassins et
bien je dirais que ces mocassins là ce
sont des mocassins écrit mais pas de cri
du québec crie un peu plus à l'ouest
alors là avec d'autres personnes je peux
identifier avec l'arrêt d'où viennent
les magasins et me dire que ce sont des
magasins d'une telle région grâce aux
motifs grâce au cuir grâce à tout ce qui
représente la nation donc en comparant
nos mocassins on peut voir la boutique
culturelle d'une nation
on aime bien montrer la nôtre aussi est
déformé mais on peut s'inspirer pour
transformer notre propre culture en la
faisant évoluer vers des nouveaux
moteurs donc rock you re max route et
mocassins sites ouverts aux communautés
autochtones
messi est aussi ouvert aux communautés
allochtones pour vous montrer les
mocassins où ils les ont trouvés
comment ça s'est passé alors les gens
partagent même 10 sport de geus et
mocassins ou telle communauté
je vous inviterai un de 15 ans présentez
vos mocassins
que vous soyez autochtone ou allochtone
dites-nous douai vient dites nous si
vous qu'ils avaient fait
mettez le mot-clic rare que remarque
2020 ou rokia max aéro c'est qu'a eus ar
m au csm avait racheté le mot-clic
espace autochtone comme ça on peut se
relier enfants de même au niveau
régional pour voir quels magasins
représentent bien le québec et où le
canada dans le souci d'une belle semaine
n'hésitez pas à partager ce bo il
n'était pas non plus à acheter des mots
clés le 15 novembre
vous pouvez même partager vos mocassins
toute l'année en régie par ce mot clic
puisque ça va exister pour toujours dans
le merveilleux web
c'est une belle semaine